ايه ده المشاهدين اكثر من 30 عاما من
العنف والجريمه ارتكبتها مجموعات اقصى
اليمين في المانيا وبتت تشكل خطرا ارهابيا
على البلاد برمتها هناك اكثر من
24,000 شخص ينتمون الى هذه المجموعه داخل
المانيا
13000 منهم يميلون للعنف وهذا ما تقوله
الاستخبارات الداخليه الالمانيه التي
بدورها تراقب حركه هذه المجموعات التي
تنشط في بعض الدول الاوروبيه والمعروفه
بعدائها للمهاجرين والمسلمين الحركه
ارتكبت مئه واربعه عشره جريمه في المانيا
خلال عام واحد فقط ما بين عام 2017 و 2018
نشاط وعنف اقصى اليمين يتركز دائما في شرق
المانيا فمثلا عام 2014 ارتكب عناصر واقصى
اليمين 47 اعتداء وكان بدوافع عنصريه في
شرق المانيا على الرغم من ان عدد السكان
فيها لا يشكل سوى
17% من اجمالي سكان البلاد نتابع
[موسيقى]
المنظمه تضمه اعضاء الناس
تدير اعمالها من خلال مجموعات صغيره عبر
شبكه الانترنت ومن المعروف ان المنظمه
تمتلك كميات كبيره من الاسلحه تقوم
بعمليات ضد قوات الامن الالمانيه وزير
الداخليه الالمانيه كان كشف ان هناك 50
شخصا من اقصى اليمين يشكلون خطرا كبيرا
وهم تحت المراقبه برلين حضاره العديد من
التنظيمات والمجموعات المؤيده لاقصى
اليمين في المانيا الا ان اغلبها لا يزال
يمارس انشطته المعديه هذه المنظمه التي
يراقبها جهاز حمايه الدستور لا تعترف
بالجمهوريه الفدراليه الالمانيه ولا ايضا
بدوله القانونه واللافه ان هذه المجموعات
تمارس انشطتها عبر احزاب سياسيه منها
البديل من اجل المانيا بديل الشباب والحزب
الوطني الديمقراطي الالماني وغيرها من
الاحساء
[موسيقى]